if I'm certain of one thing in life it's
that there are cheap laptops and great
laptops but cheap laptops are never
great and great laptops are never cheap
that's become the Chromebook problem for
$250 you get good for the price web
focus laptops but they have flimsy
plastic that feels like a toy low
resolution washed out screens and
trackpads that make you want to throw
something at them but then there's
Google's very own high-end Chromebook
pixel which as you would expect for its
high price has none of those flaws and
today it's getting even better with a
bigger battery faster processor faster
charging technology and lots of other
new tricks I would have told you you
were insane to buy the first pixel which
came out two years ago all that money
for a laptop that just browses the web
but not anymore not only is the improved
pixels price down to a slightly more
affordable $1000 but these days it's
much easier to live in a web browser the
new pixel looks almost identical to the
old pixel and I'm actually fine with
that the solid aluminium design makes it
one of the most well crafted laptops
ever it looks great and feels even
better I have a serious crush on this
laptop the backlit keyboard is sturdy
the trackpad is incredibly responsive to
multi-touch gestures and the twelve
point eight inch high-res touchscreen is
crisp and incredibly bright but good
luck trying to use it outdoors
I do wish Google would have shaved off a
little bit of the thickness and weight
of the system especially considering it
has this new USB type-c port which is
much thinner the tiny socket charges up
the laptop really fast in a little more
than an hour
it also has bi-directional power so you
can use the port to charge other gadgets
the big excitement is that the plug is
reversible no more failed attempts to
plug in your USB cable upside down even
better you need to charge the pixel that
often the battery lasted over 11 hours
it also has this cool battery meter on
the lid yet the biggest difference
between this pixel and the pixel from
two years ago doesn't have really
anything to do with hardware it has to
do with the progression
the web and us Chrome OS is still pretty
much just a Chrome browser though with
some pretty cool tricks
but unlike a few years ago so many
desktop apps now have web versions still
many don't there's still no Skype or
iTunes many apps and websites won't work
when you don't have an internet
connection and peripheral support
especially printing is a major issue
then while it comes with one terabyte of
google drive space there's only 32
gigabytes of local storage that's why
the pixel or even a $250 Chromebook
still isn't for everyone
laptops like the Dell XPS 13 or Apple's
MacBook Air are more affordable and much
more practical if the pixel will price
at around $800 it would be a much
stronger alternative but if you've
decided that living in Chrome is right
for you then it's time to ponder this
deep question do you want a cheap
Chromebook or a great one